the next session is talking about
mechanism design risk neutrality right
hey my name is - Baracus
thanks a lot for having me here so I'm
going to talk about making this making
time beyond which control a team I'm
currently a postdoc at UT Austin so
let's start with a brief introduction to
what mechanic design is so there are
several definitions for mega and design
the one at a particular like is the
system of we'll have a system of
individual rational agents and our task
as a designer to design an incentive
structure for a given in order to
achieve a given objective so what is the
most famous example of this is auctions
who have a set of self-interested buyers
interested in an item that the
auctioneers want to sell and the
auctioneers goal is to maximize the
revenue but given there are multiple
people here they're interested in other
topics Cormega and design is applicable
let me give you some more examples so
yeah and the way it sorry so the way to
achieve this is they elicit bits - no -
they're mine the allocation and the
payment another example would be
transportation networks our goal here
would be to minimize congestion drivers
are interested in minimizing their
personal route the time of the personal
real-time well as our goal is to
minimize in total congestion and the
incentive structure here would be a form
of negative incentives for example
placed on several routes that
incentivizes some change in the routing
in the university drivers are choosing
so that we get a total
Dukan in total minimize the total
contestant another example from energy
is the energy markets the particular
topic that I like is demand response
what what do we do in demand response we
are trying to incentivize energy
consumer to reduce the energy demand
during peak times and how do we achieve
this will provide positive insane
through coupons for reductions in energy
consumption so our goal here is to for
example let's say we this is an
experiment has been done in Houston 2016
where people were given some monetary
incentives if they reduced their AC
temperature assailing the increase that
their AC temperature during peak times
and there was very positive feedback
about the effect of these incentives so
for like computational perspectives why
are they were they smart what why are
these problems interesting first of all
traditional this helping started from an
economics perspective so there's a lot a
lot of work in make and design in the
economic literature however due to all
of these applications are increasing in
scale and there are actually some
real-time combinational demands think of
online auctions happening on the
internet or demand response that has to
happen within an hour we have some need
for in an interest for efficient
algorithms and the main question would
like to study is what is the trade-off
between the quality of the outcome and
the computational tractability so back
to bidets comments before is this is the
field of algorithm mechanic design were
where our main goal is to study what is
this trade-off between how how can we do
better mechanism and also respect
computational constraints and be fast
and also sometimes also have simple
solutions so far everything at all so
far has nothing to do with risk is the
standard mechanic design and the last
slide is about algorithmic and somehow
algorithmic thought can help in solving
these problems so what about risk
so a typical assumption that is in
mechanic's design aspect and especially
the way that in algorithmic and then we
started the problems is that we assume
that the agents are risk neutral so
every our optimality conditions and our
everything we do as relies heavily on
this risk neutrality but in reality in
practice agents are not in the
indifferent risk to very famous examples
for that is auctions where in practice
usually buyers overbeat compared to what
the theory would predict for the best
response if there were is neutral so
usually agents beats more in a first
price auction
then the theory would suggest who it
implies some sort of risk-averse
behavior in contrast for energy demand
response this particular study that I
referred before they're using randomized
coupon have greater impact on affecting
the customer behavior so so their
consumer behavior sorry it should be
consumer so we see that in this case we
have some sort of a risk seeking
behavior where a randomized reward would
elicit better response or if you want
fix on the type of response you want you
can do it in a cheaper way if you use
some sort of lotteries so both these
examples in motivate the study of
mechanisms and the computational aspect
of mechanisms when there is no risk
neutrality when we have some sort of
either risk-averse or risk seeking
behavior so the toko purview I will
focus on a single item auction because
this is the one the one topic that has
been studied and there is a lot of work
behind this and as you most results here
usually carry over in different settings
and I'm going to give some over you for
what optimal auctions are for risk in
term agents then I'm going to talk about
what happens if we how can we take
advantage of risk-averse behavior and
how complicated the optimal algorithm
become then I'm going to go to the risk
seeking behavior and so how we can take
advantage of very sickening heavier by
using a simple solution instead and then
I will conclude with some future
directions what I think are important
topics in this area ok so let's start so
let's let me define first that the
setting of a single item auction so
we'll have an auctioneer that has it
single item to sell there are n buyers
interested in the item and it's by I has
value di for the item the important
thing here is a piece value is private
so this value is known only to the
I the auctioneer and the rest biased
instead they don't know that value what
they know is that it's drawn from some
distribution F so simplistic here I
assume that this is common distribution
but all of this can be extended if the
values are drawn from heterogeneous
distributions and that should be the
setting and the add again what does how
does a mekinese an option look like in
such a setting the buyers report beats
to the auctioneer then then the
auctioneer given these beats will decide
on the allocation probability and a
payment for its buyer I so that amount
here will tell you what is the
probability of receiving the item given
the bits of everyone else and this is
exactly the payment that you have to pay
the buyers goal in this setting in this
original setting would be to maximize
that amount
what is this amount this is the value
that you have for the item
the real value times the allocation
probability minus the payment so the
goal of the buyer I would be to maximize
that quantity whereas our goal as a
auctioneer in this case could be to
maximize the revenue would be the
summation of the payments our typical
assumption in such a setting is that a
mechanism is truthful if it's the best
interest for the for each buyer to
report their true value and we can there
is a lot of rich theory behind why we
can actually restrict our attention to
only truthful making yes distribution is
identical for all layers and for this
presentation I assumed is identical but
all of this work can be done with
different distributions I will get back
to this when I present the main
characterization I'll tell you how
things may be a little bit different
so so far that's the model so let's see
an example and a very trivial example
with a single buyer this is going to be
an example I'm going to use throughout
the whole talk to show you the
difference what happens when in the
presence of a risk neutral a risk
aversion a risk seeker seeking buyer so
I have a single buyer with a value V
drawn from a distribution unit from zero
one that's a standard toy example yes
so the buyer knows is fairly yes
distribution interview of the self of
the seller and in this case only the
seller but in move for multiple buyers
is also going to be from a perspective
of the other buyers so its buyer knows
doesn't know exactly the value of other
buyer they know only the distribution
and they all agree on the distribution
yes this is a creative we agree on the
distribution yes so this should be like
a market research or something like this
is according to market risks all we know
is that this value is drawn from some
distribution yeah this is a common prior
model everyone agrees on the
distribution and for this case question
my the symmetric part this are the way
independent
yes yeah the opmod is going to be
dominic strategy but not necessarily
when we ask you risk right but yeah so
what is how would you so I'm giving you
the situation where you're an auctioneer
you have a single buyer that's what you
know about this buyer how would you
proceed with designing an auction or a
scheme for this case well the most
typical thing you would imagine doing is
to offer a price a pricing mechanism
right essentially offer a
take-it-or-leave-it offer of P right
what
but what does this mean is that the
buyer will accept if the value is over P
so that's essentially using the previous
notation would be that we receive the
value of the buyer and then we allocate
it if the values of RP and zero
otherwise and we have a new charge then
P if they win or not but you know you
can view it both ways this is the simple
way this is the formal way so and that
and if we restrict our attention to this
sort of pricing mechanism our goal would
be to in their goalies maximize revenue
we have to solve that problem so the
probability of this is the price that we
put the tag the price that we put on the
item times the probability of this item
being sold and solving that equation we
get a P of mouthpiece equal to 1/2 I
won't get a revenue of 1/4 that's
everyone that knows a little bit of rare
maximization this is the typical example
of a first encounter so and then the
next question is what about the optimal
action for this setting what if we can
allow well what if we allow
randomization or multiple offers so any
sort of crazy things can we do better
well the answer is no this is the best
thing we could hope for this simple
pricing mechanism is optimal for the
case of single buyer this is due to
Marshalls characterization of the
optimal auction
one of the most celebrated results in
mecca and design and macroeconomics I
would say in general
and also that implies for multiple
buyers of course and what we get here is
the second price auction with the
reserve now back to your question here
the reason why because I wanted to have
it a simple description here was that if
people have a coming from a symmetric
distribution then it ends up being the
second production with a common reserve
if they have from different distribution
it's not the second price it's slightly
different but it's still very simple in
that in the sense of its deterministic
its dominance strategies that we
described before but it's slightly
harder to describe so that's the only
reason why I use the common prior so the
symmetric prior so this is the situation
so we should be happy and this and there
are some things that we know someone
could try to study more here for example
what if we use this auction in a setting
where agents are not semantic and
several questions like that have been
extensively been studing in algorithm
against and literature but the thing
that I would like to change from this
standard model today is as I said there
is neutrality so this whole theorem this
characterization is heavily reliant on
the fact that the agent is risk neutral
so essentially that the 18 is maximizing
that amount here
however so let's give you an excellent
give you an example to depict what risk
reality means here is if I give you an
option one which is the price of a half
an option two which is a price of one
with probability 1/2 and price of zero
otherwise Richmond child implies that
both of these look the same for you like
and at every age and this they can't
distinguish between district this is as
you feel like at least that's what I
feel that in practice that shouldn't be
a decision that they would like they
would not these are not interchangeable
these are different things the
perspective of someone making a decision
in practice so yes as I said that is a
buyer like this option the same but not
not what we expect so to model risk in
this case we're going to use the
standard and traditional notion of
expected in the theory according to this
utility the agent is maximizing a
utility over their rewards so if we
perceive that amount here as a reward
then our goal is to maximize the
expectation of a utility function of
this reward the reason I use capital
here because these are essentially the
random variable so these are essentially
what we get here is the realizations
before you could you could think about
this case here that could be like the
expectation of X so that would be taking
the expectation inside here is taking
the expectation outside or some within
the function U so given that notation
the signal definition sorry how would we
define various mutual behavior well a
new original agent is an age that uses a
linear you so using linear U is
equivalent in that quantity is
equivalent to maximizing the thing
that's inside an expectation so we just
get what we had before but if we want a
risk aversion
we get we get with a concave you never
want a risk seeker a risk second we get
with a convex you so by changing the it
is your accordingly we get the behavior
to out like half so let's do a sanity
check here or let's go back to our
Janell exempt or the example that we had
you have option one that seemed to be
seems to be the one that should be
preferred by the risk-averse agent and
this should be what they wanted should
be preferred by there is clothing there
is seeking / clothing agent so the risk
of agents the risk averse agent using
just the definition of concavity we can
see that they should prefer this whereas
this agent should prefer the other
option that's early by this definition
now the the question the natural
question is what happens when we don't
coverage neutral agents now I described
to you the optimal action for each
control agents and now Todd suddenly I
tell you well your agents are not that
is neutral anymore they are risk averse
to risk seekers or something should you
worry
suddenly whatever I was doing doesn't
produce as much revenue as it did before
so thus there are risk averse or seeking
agents negatively impacting the revenue
in this case you think about it should
that be the case no the optimal risk
Muta auction is deterministic right so
if you Pro if since since the optimal
was deterministic if you silently
streets to risk-averse or is seeking
agents whatever was giving you the
optimal revenue for that for the risk in
third case still giving you the same
revenue we don't express risk
behavioural agents do not change their
decisions on deterministic actions so
you are as good as before using the
optimal misciagna auction but you're
losing potential right so the idea here
is that adding this assuming that the
agents have some sort of behavior
towards risk either risk aversion or
risk seeking there is some advantage to
in brackets exploit that behavior and
obtain more revenue sounds bad but think
about like think of the other
application web that could be good
yes deterministic we're still venomous
associated with other people yeah but
I'm nighttime I'm focusing with a single
barrier I don't know so I'm I'm doing
all this work for the single-payer spot
so right now the exam so yeah should
have said that I'm focusing on a single
part so right now everything is
deterministic you should be happy that
everything you were doing before you can
do it again you can suffer the same
price and you get the same revenue but
you can get take advantage of so let's
revisit that example and consider the
case of a risk-averse agent so again we
have our Priory's Union from zero one
and let's assume like that particular
utility which is the square root so we
just simply think the first thing that
came into my mind so now remember before
what we did is work we're offering a
single price if when that was the winner
so now I'm telling I'm changing a little
bit the algorithm by adding an extra
choice so instead of offering only that
option I'm giving you the option of
buying the item at the price of a half
with certainty I'm also telling you that
look there is this lottery you can pick
that you can obtain the a what's what
what's going to happen is the moment you
pick that lottery then I'll throw a coin
the biased coin that with probability
1/4 you'll win the item and then an only
value were going to pay another quarter
so they'll have to decide which of them
is best for you now what do you expect
to happen in this case well
if we look if we look by adding that so
if we just remove the option two we get
exactly the same reason that we would
get in there is now setting what will
get the revenue for quarter right where
every agent above a half is getting
option one and every other is in below a
half is not taking any offer now we have
introduced that option here what's going
to happen is first of all everything
that has a value below a quarter is
going to not going to pick anything
every one between a quarter and a half
is going to pick that option because
that strictly gives them some positive
utility whereas before they were getting
nothing but what happens is some agents
that are in the proximity of a half we
want to street to the bottom option
because they were getting almost nothing
before and now they have an option of
getting something right so you this is a
you introduced a box the option you
suddenly get some new types that will be
accepting your price but now you lose
someone from the bottom of the of the
one that was giving you the highest
price so let's calculate that we just
find the sweet spot where that happens
well that happens to be 31 over 60
that's very close to 1/2 so what means
is that all of the agents that are
between 50 160 and one are going to pick
that choice between a half a quarter an
effective one over 60 I'm going to pick
that option and then the rest are going
to pick nothing so how much is the
revenue of this we'll get slightly over
a quarter so we did better we introduced
a new option and we did better something
that was not possible with risk neutral
agents what is happening here
intuitively we could do the same thing
with risk neutral agents but what would
happen is this could backfire
necessarily we would lose more
everything that would gain by reducing
that auction here but they had used
probability of that of that option here
isn't it makes these agents of our risk
averse not so eager to drop these
certain choices that they have and go
down to that a
cheaper but more but very risky in
brackets option so that's that so this
the amount of people that leak to the
bottom options is shrink massively to to
the risk aversion so and generally
foolish covers agent there is this is
just an example this has been this is a
problem has been extensively studied
these are the two papers that if you
like risk aversion you should definitely
read this are they several papers in
this field and so they have studied and
understand what is the optimal auctions
in for some relatively severe
assumptions and this concern
considerably complicated you can
actually Martin doing the trigger that
before by feeding options all the time
and eventually you know further further
further increasing the revenue it could
get so something like that happens could
happen in the optimal auction there are
some work tries to find approximation
but that's what I think is what I think
is the most interesting direction for
the research to go in this field in this
particular problem is to just identify
approximations that can do good compared
to the very complicated optimal auction
and generally this intuition that first
transaction performs better in the
presence of discovers agents so that's
what we know about discovers agents okay
yes so in this any okay yes you're right
in the I lost over it for the case of a
single buyer this bidding game can be
done by offering like there is an
equivalency between bidding and offering
options
I would what I would do is I would
reverse engineer exactly or how you
should behave and I will tell you I will
behave optimally for you and I'll commit
to that and then you just put your value
and I behave exactly like that so if
your values between this and this I'm
giving you that option if your values
between this and this I'm giving you
that option if I do that there is an
equivalency between yes it's not clear
because this particular implementation
is like the this standard notion of how
an auction should run like is not
necessarily how they're really being
implemented this is a way of unifying
how how exactly we define an auction
through an allocation and the prepend
probability for the case of a single
buyer it's much more intuitive to think
of like there is an equivalency between
that definition and me offering you
options and then chooses what you like
so instead of running doing the auction
by bidding all I'm doing is these are
the options I'm giving to you choose
your best the corresponding optimal so
the corresponding version of that
auction with allocation function is just
the one that helps you I'm going to do
the best response for you just tell me
the truth and I'm going to do the best
thing for you these are the options I'm
going to consider I'm going to just do
what you would do if I gave you this
option yes yes you can do that by better
speeding your value and then the
opposite that you define the auction
there's and
abilities if I had many small pieces
exactly
I was actually some time was trying to
solve that connection he does I don't
think I've reached the conclusion I'm
not sure about that answer but that was
something I was thinking at some point
so yes yeah yeah but this is kind of
what you do like I sense that you're
offering you're saying that what what
this can grow like is going to be okay
I'm gonna Sicily can extract your value
by saying you beat your you tell I'm
gonna tell your value slightly under
your value but I'm guaranteeing to you
that a good probability of allocation
and the next person is going to get a
slightly less but you charge a little
bit less maybe what eventually you get
is you get you'll end the special value
and you charge them for it right yeah so
I think I don't know how much time I
have but
ten minutes so yeah so that's existing
work so let's go to risk seeking ideas
because kind of like this is my
contribution in this talk either through
this so the main question I would like
to ask is our optimal options for risk
is the risk seeking agents as
complicated as the risk averse
counterparts as we saw and eluded and
briefly described risk averse optimal
auction design is complicated and it may
involve a very complicated algorithm the
mechanism so we ask this question here
now one problem will reach with risk
seeking agencies the problem we're under
extreme case of listing behavior the
mekinese obtains infinite revenue so
think about the case that you can always
oh if an engine is infinitely
risk-averse you can offer them an
infinite gamble where you can get
infinite money we circumvent this by as
always assuming an upper bound M on the
Mac on the expose payment so we say in
no circumstance you could ever pay more
than M or charge someone more than m and
you can think of it as the bias have
some some sort of a budget but they
cannot go beyond ever paying from their
pocket that money so given that
assumption we let's go and revisit that
example one we started for various
coverage case before so again we have
this and then we consider the
exponential between two here a to the X
minus one and let's say the maximum
value here is two right so the 18 is
between 0 & 1 but who can tell them at
most Oh
so how would we proceed with taking
advantage of risk second behavior here
would offer one choice now we will offer
the item with probability 1 but instead
of offering at a fixed price will use a
randomized price so P is equal to M the
maximum value with probability 1/2 and p
0 otherwise so we are telling them I'm
going to give you just a
take-it-or-leave-it offer but it has to
be randomized like this so it's a gamble
essentially and then the next question
is how many people will go for a gamble
for what types of this in the support of
this distribution this gives them
positive utility well you can just
compute it and roughly around point five
six that's what you get you get actually
revenue of point four four which is
significantly more than point 25 so what
we show here is by adding an extra
option
what did not by not without our the next
eruption by just editing the single
take-it-or-leave-it offer adding
randomness we actually managed to
improve the revenue in the presence of a
sprig seeking item that shouldn't be
very surprising writes or listing agent
wants Gamble's instead of giving them a
random a fixed price we give them an
example which they like more and they
are willing to essentially go negative
from a risk neutral perspective to go to
our gamble but the most interesting
thing is yes that should be the first
intuition but is that the best you can
do
well the answer is actually yes which is
recent work with after IKEA student
Jerry Yang and myself where the optimal
auction for Six Sigma buyer is a
randomized take-it-or-leave-it offer the
only but we are being a certain series
the exponential utility functions so we
relying on that assumption to show that
and we extend that to multiple buyers
and it's actually kind of interesting
that we discover some sort of like a new
auction that is we'll call it the loser
pay auction maybe you're familiar with
what's called the all pay auction where
essentially you pay your bit in the
beginning and then you you always pay
your bid think of the same thing but if
you also get a refund whatever you paid
your ticket back to make it to make the
losses and their winds as extreme as
possible and this hacks will happen to
also be optimal for that for this case
also swimming exponential function and
the question is how limiting is
exponential in the functions well
unfortunately it's not sufficient
one option offering just a single
randomized take-it-or-leave-it
is not optimal for quadratic utility
functions so we first got our lower
bound there a counter example that
that's not generally optimal but we
don't know yet if we need infinite or
how many we need or how much exactly
we'll lose the only thing with the only
loss was found here it was very very
minimal so they still open questioners
what is the optimal auction for a
channel for general convex utility
function and if this happened to be very
complicated
can we approximate with an optimal
mechanism now I'm kind of concluding
with these two interesting cases that
are so to you about how we can exploit a
risk behavior in auctions and I want to
finish with like three directions that I
think are interesting to study in this
topic and generally if someone is
interested in using behavioral
assumptions in some sort of an algorithm
problem the following so dynamic
settings in dynamic settings because of
the external seventy about the future
for example not only I don't know about
other bias values but I also don't know
about my future valuations I have four
things that will happen in the future so
there is a sort of like massive increase
in like uncertainty which makes things
with risk even more complicated for that
particularly optimal options like for
dynamic settings are tailored for
risking charity and actually have almost
zero revenue with risk-averse agents so
we had an example in the static setting
where by not taking advantage of risk
a version we were not harming ourselves
we're just not gaining as much as we
could but for dynamic settings optimal
options starting failing if we have this
conversion for example so that's a very
interesting topic for see what happens
here another one is they expect utility
theory I mentioned briefly that this is
the traditional way of modeling risk
there are some other interesting has
several flaws I think some some prior
talks people who are like I think if
thought you had talked a little bit
about that but experimental has several
flaws the typical model of utility
fields used in behavioural scientist is
the cumulative prospect theory where
think of it as an addition to the
typical theory where people have also
subjective form of probabilities where
they have a weighting function where
they can weight the probabilities apart
from actually applying the utility
function of the wealth and and can cover
several cases where they expect tilde
fails and finally and maybe it's I think
the most important one is the risk
robustness where all of this talk was
assuming that even if we agree on a good
risk model that we all like all of this
resulted ascribe really require that you
know the exact experimenters perfectly
but this is even more unrealistic than
you know like we are already assuming
who don't know their values how can we
know their risk parameters so it's kind
of like can we do all of this work in a
risk robust manner where we design
algorithms that work in a family for a
family of risk parameters rather than
for a fixed one and if you're asked the
question can we do all the last three
together that's not possible
another recent work and with that I
would like to thank you
[Applause]
yes so what apartment straining people
think about the magnetic design is
expose directionality which roughly says
that you don't want to charge your
agents money without giving them
something which plane but selling
lottery spy lights we assumed we assumed
interim IR of course because otherwise
you wouldn't be able not sure I I for
risk-averse to come or risk-averse you
can obtain social welfare without
violating anything actually the optimal
is always it's the exposed IR is always
optimal for risk-averse because the
optimal Lottery only charges you if you
win forest covers and it's only the case
for is seeking behaviour where you're
actually when I go beyond their
otherwise you can't really take
advantage of their is taking behavior so
now whether or not there is room for for
exposure Chanel and risk seekers I'm not
sure about this I wouldn't be surprised
if the result says to cannot do more but
also maybe it's likely now